we're flown into palmer by military
helicopter
it's the only way to the center after
militant extremists rampage
through the town in the remote northern
cabo delgado province
the town's now heavily fortified with
soldiers and special forces spread
throughout
it was the most audacious attack yet in
mozambique by militants linked to isis
and terrified residents are still only
just emerging after hiding in the bush
ever since they're all very hungry
they've survived on root vegetables and
rain water
up till now
we're the first international
broadcasters to make it to the center
since the storming of palmer
we're with the governor of the province
who's also seeing the destruction for
the first time those are people
returning the people there
yeah they're returning they feel they
feel it's safe
the dead are still laying in the open in
the street
they haven't been able to retrieve them
up until now
and there are modest attempts to give
some respect to those who died in this
terrifying
and violent assault
we saw a body in what appeared to be
camouflage clothing
wearing an ammunition vest an outfit
favored by the terror group known as
al-shabab or isis mozambique
the attackers swept through palmer
setting fire to shops
homes and offices all the town's key
infrastructure was targeted including
the hospital
and the administrative offices and the
mobile phone network was destroyed
how can you guarantee it won't happen
again at this i can't say
this i can't say uh what i have to say
is that
we we are we are here with our troops
and
uh we we feel we feel okay
we saw the first residents to trickle
back into the town
after hiding for nearly two weeks
grabbing what they could from the
vandalized shots
these are desperate times for palmer's
residents
the struggle to survive is not yet over
for those who managed to escape the
attackers
tensions are still incredibly high the
troops we were with arrested three young
men who they say were acting
suspiciously
that was a gunshot and we were
immediately hurried away and out of the
town
the military may have moved into palmer
but there are still multiple challenges
facing them
the attack has halted work on the 60
billion
liquefied natural gas project outside
palma on the afunji
peninsula this was meant to transform
the fortunes of this desperately poor
region
now security's been stepped up the
project is vitally important for
mozambique's economy
but in the smaller fungi airport
terrified palmer families who've taken
refuge there
told us how they fled for their lives so
i started ran away to my home
i went to pick up my family my wife and
the kids all of them then we went to the
bush for the people there was followers
in the back
so after that when we jumped we jumped
one river
we found the people with the gun they
were shootings one and one pips another
and there's
another people also just chipping at the
people so we tried to run away
you saw this i saw this with my my arm
some of them with my shirt
what were they doing they are killing
people how
they shoot people even the following are
shooting us
then we
the governor went to try to reassure the
thousands of people who fled the
insurgents
and have now taken sanctuary in the
katunda resettlement village on the edge
of the lng site
this village was built for those
displaced by the huge gas project
but the numbers have now swelled to
bursting
we're hungry we're hungry they keep
telling us and with all unaided flights
halted because of the militant attacks
these people have had
very little to eat or drink in nearly a
fortnight
they're all saying how hungry they are
and making
and for the us to stop this conflict
look at them they're all calling they're
all saying food
we want food
[Music]
the governor promised they'd get help
and be able to return to palmer within
days
but they're getting more and more
desperate and more worryingly for
mozambique
is how it protects these people controls
this militant insurgency and stops it
from spreading
alex crawford sky news and cover delgado
mozambique